okay I had to say that
sorry we're talking about the fan say
okay do we finish that class there's
always a good delay oh no I guess not
you see fr this is
okay we'll take her out I'll take rads
Khan hello
hey bye hey just kidding let's go oh
wait I like to keep my horse is sweaty
Hanna nothing's better than a sweaty or
so except marry the right house yeah but
even then it's still close second okay
okay it's look for a hand Rach I that
guy over there freaking far
okay I've got I can just like cut
through this
that's say wait that's getting I can't
you out there that got a picking trace
everywhere yeah go make a mess I'm on up
can I get out bait yet
yeah we just kill a suckers hey second
step in animals Wow Wow yeah Melton tell
you that
ah it's over walls past never to be
restored forget they're happening
the Sun was waning and the dust went
cruising like blood thought to myself
backing on there all right person tiny
what the hang is that
nice people burn anything that's gonna
work
that's a sass
it's paragraph
I think is this that you got some a nice
our what I'm I had some Homer I like
that
well peace of mind to you kinda heads up
here by myself now
financing called and Reich is in there
guys this hey that's him
hey now looking there's something maybe
something in this chair can't something
in his jerkin damn he's cold as ice yeah
yeah need to check his pockets trousers
are stiff as he found out to dry
midwinter
should check his boots blood congealed
hidden in his boot gotta fit a keyhole
somewhere nearby hopefully hmm so my
first wife said I might as well take
this stuff's not like he's gonna not
like he's gonna use it you know you know
just thinking I had Nina there's a draft
gotta be a space under this rubble I
guess I should do some clean yes sir
yeah sir okay what just fallen Arawa
misaeng strange a bloody bear and
problems a kidnapped
what the hell what is that behind there
just a couple are insane Oh interesting
this guy got traps all over the place
all right a lot of crowns on there
where's that
a ledger payment for a sack of grain
amount due for a charcoal shipment
Hendrik was masquerading as a merchant
what's this notes among the ledger
entries
however my not clever enough interesting
headings missing and wanted subject
appeared in Skellig ax also cited in
novigrad appearance unchanged ashen hair
scar on her face avoids contact with
others caution advised and being
observed dog ran off water in bucket
strange glow observed drunken swine
so-called reason unknown talked to bear
in it clashed with a witch subject
landed conflict ensued find the witch
talk to the peasantry somehow they
learned Henrik was looking for Siri
that's the torture too late my only
leads the Baron and some witch damn
yeah can to that yeah I guess I guess
that's it that's an F card in connection
Thank You Peppa thank you for watching